バトルフェーズ
カオスMAX攻撃
はい、俺の勝ち
(ハッハッハッ)
4000かー
の貫通
よんたんになるから....
4000×2で8000ダメージ
(くそ.....)
MAX!!!
いいの~?!
なんで、怒ってるんですか。
今日ですね、あの～
撮影をしていたと
外で
なにも無い海の
近くで撮ってたんですけど
まさきと俺で行ったと、そこに
行って着くと
まあちょっと
５、６人の男女のグループがいたと
男女のグループがいて．．．
うわ、はじめさ～ん
お～い！みたいな
はじめ～！お～い！
今からそっち行くからお～い！みたいな
まあ全然ね、来たら来たで撮るんだけど
まあ、一応ね撮影もかなり急いでたから
そのあと彼らは
我々を盗撮したと
暴力はだめだよ
で、まあ結局俺とまさきは撮影をしたかったんだけども
彼らが、その
撮った盗撮した
盗撮自体だめだよ
盗撮自体だめなんだけどその
撮った写真をツイッターで呟きました
で、結構いろんな人が見ちゃって
ここにいますって
はじめんが、川にいたよみたいなのを呟いちゃって
それを見て
結構人が来ました
何人くらい？
10人以上くらいちょっと人が来ちゃって
まあ結局その日は
残念ながら撮影を中断しました
なんかこうさ、分かる？俺のこの…
写真、なんか
写真良いですかみたいな一言言ってくれれば全然撮るんだけどさぁ
こっちもさ、その撮影前でさ、
まじな顔で荷物とか本気で運んでるところを撮られたらやっぱ嫌なわけよ
やっぱ無断で、勝手に撮って勝手にツイッターにあげちゃうっていうのはね…
そうなんすよ…
いや～、ちょっと非常にね悲しいというか
全然、あの、外で見かけて声かけてくれたりは全然良いんですよ
写真良いですかって言ってくれたらもちろん全然撮りますし
急いでないときはね
写真も撮りますし
もう全然、なんか
いいんですけど、その
盗撮はまずダメだし
むちゃくちゃ嫌な気持ちになるし
犯罪にもなるし
まじでそれを呟いちゃうと皆来ちゃうわけよ
その、地元の人はね
ここだって分かってる
で、結局来て、なんか大事なったからまさきと俺は結構荷物持ってたんですけど
担いで大急ぎで逃げましたと
という感じで今日一日は
なんか盗撮されてたくさんの人に追われて
やりたいこともできずに
なんとなく終わった一日でした
すげえ悲しい動画になったね
いやあまずね、何が言いたいのかといいますと
あの～とりあえず
我々も人間ですから
盗撮は
だめですほんとに
俺たちに限ったことじゃないよ
そうそうそうそう
全然もうなんかほかの人もそうだし
電車内とかでもそうだし
知らない人とかをね、勝手に撮るのはだめなことです
友達とかを撮るなら良いと思うんですけど
そこはちょっと違うなと思いました
非常に我々嫌な気持ちをしております
いやいや、嫌な気持ちしてるよ
しかもそれがね、何回も
やられるからね
まさきなんて、あの○○○なんて言ってたから
言ってないよ
こうやってね、動画のほうにも影響出ちゃうからね
いやほんとそうだよまじで
どうなるかっていうのが分かんないのかな
だって来るじゃんそりゃあもう見た人は悪くないじゃん
そうそう来るのは分かるよ
俺もだってそんなのあれだよ
だって、あみたがいますって静岡にいますって言われたら俺はそこに走っていくかもしれないし
そこはちょっと察してほしかったなっていう
なんでね、もう来てくださったことは全然良いです
なんか会いたいって思ってくれただけで嬉しいんですけど
呟いちゃうとみんな来ちゃうから
まあそもそも盗撮はだめだよっていう
お話を今日はしたかったです
まあ嬉しいことだけどさ
なかなかね～、大変だよ
ちくしょ～
悔しいね
悔しいと思ってる？
見てくれる人が増えてからさ、やりづらくなったところも結構あるから
まあそこは何とか、我々がうまいことやっていかなきゃいけないんですけど
それでもやっぱ、どうしようもないことがあるんで
皆さんの協力がないとできないかなって思ってるんで
もしね、その、撮影してる時に見かけて、なんかやってるなって思っても
あまり写真とか撮らないでほしいなっていうことを言いたいです
いや～、こういうことがまた起きると
我々はもっと外に出なくなります
いや、悲しいよ
怒ってるんだとりあえず俺は
怒ってるんだよ！！！
てかまあ、呟いた人も
結局そうやってファンの人から叩かれたりとかもしちゃうからね
まあ確かに
ネットに、SNSに出すってことは
結局みんなから何言われても
仕方ないとこがあるんで
それでもいいなら
いや、呟いちゃだめだ！
うんだめだよ
だめだよ！呟いちゃだめだよ
ただ、呟いちゃうと結局ね
その、見ちゃう人も怒るから
良くないっすよ、ほんとに
ただね、やっぱその撮った子たちも悪気がなかったかもしんないんで
まあ今後は、気を付けましょう
っていう話
盗撮された？
も、あるしなんか俺に似てる人がいたっつってその人も勝手に盗撮されててかわいそうだった
だめだよ甘い甘い甘い
ネットのマナーがなってないそれじゃあネットは、この現代は生きていけないよ！！！
てかさ、分かるよね
まじカメラ向けてたらすごい分かりますから
あきらかにこうやってるから
みんなほんと、ほとんどバレてる
まじ、ほんと分かりやすいよ
全然撮りますけど、撮りますけどもせめて一声かけていただきたい
こっちにもタイミングってのがあるんで
告白みたいになっちゃった
心の準備が
怖かったね
５，６人でさ、なんかテトラポットからこうやってカメラ向けてくるんだよ
恐怖ですよ
いや怖かったよ
今回ちょっと久しぶりに物申すみたいな感じになってしまったんですが
ひとまず、俺の動画を見てるやつらだけでも
心エロ
俺の動画を見てるやつらだけでも
心得といてくれ
盗撮は、犯罪です
SNSは気をつけましょう
映画館は…静かに
まっ、こんくらいですかね
とりあえずネットのマナーは気をつけて守っていきましょう
非常に今日は苦しかったです
こんな感じで終わるの？
悲しくね？
これまさき、狂ってみてよ
いやだよぉ
一回だけやってほんとほんと
やだぁ、それ絶対さ
めちゃくちゃさあ
誇張して使うもん
お願いお願い
ちょ、マネしてマネして一回だけ
ね、お願いほんとに
じゃ、俺のマネするだけでいいから。いきます